all right everybody we are on our way to
a very hot labor day yes we are i hope
you're prepared for that i want you to
have fun but we want you to be safe for
sure temperatures gonna be way above
normal look at those beautiful blue
skies out there so we've got some 70s
around the valley other areas like green
valley you're hanging on to some low 80s
aliante at 80 degrees so is summerlin in
the lake 74 out at red rock not much in
the way of wind so if you want to get
out early and do a bike ride or a jog
get in that golf game early before it
gets too hot is a good time lots of 70s
from boulder city to searchlight 80s in
laughlin nice 60s in indian springs 56
in caliente reno 54. by the way the wolf
pack beat the cal bears saturday night
wow go wolf pack you and our 85 up on
the mountain today safe hiking there
will be some breezes but not too bad
later in the week now a chance of
thunderstorms up in the higher
elevations and along the colorado river
valley but not today just hot and sunny
out at the lake at 108 degrees cal door
fire in northern california 215 000
acres but again better containment over
the weekend so they are letting some
folks back in from those mandatory
evacuations last week that is great news
staying dry and hot
there are heat watches through all
through central california southeast
california those are heat warnings just
like southern nevada starting today
before noon and go all the way through
wednesday evening at eight o'clock so
107 today when we should be 98
okay when are those numbers coming down
not till the end of the week really 107
today 108 tomorrow 107 105 on thursday
eventually we get into the low triple
digits for the weekend but man it is
going to take a while to shake off this
extra heat be careful this week